Microsoft will be talking to us about a
notebook and serverless function
um you do request that uh you say the
questions you the end of that
presentation well there'll be a thankful
question and answer and now I have to
make it I'll come around to you so that
your question could be done by everyone
else that's what I've been on the
recording
speak up
all right thank you
[Applause]
is everyone for coming
um yeah my name is Krishnan I'm a cyber
liability engineer at Microsoft I work
on the uh Azure Cosmos CD team
and uh today I'm here to talk about
notebooks as serverless functions
so
before I get into that I just want to
emphasize just how awesome these are
notebooks are I am speaking at Pi data
so I think a lot of people here would
agree with me there but just um just to
hammer this uh you know Jupiter
notebooks are great for both beginners
and experienced developers there's all
kinds of information tooling like for
data science data visualization in a
deeper ecosystem and
Coating in a Jupiter notebook is unlike
most Ides the debugging experiences
like really excellent it's very
intuitive and it's also a great place to
share work you can share like code
tables charts um markdown
amongst you know collaborators which is
makes it far superior than just using
normal text files
but as good as they are there is a
problem
um taking Jupiter notebooks to
production is no easy task there's no
one way to do it as there would be with
like a Java project or a normal like
python uh python file uh every YouTuber
notebook needs to go to production it's
in its own custom way it might need
parts of it to be Rewritten if not the
whole thing to be Rewritten maybe in a
different language
it might involve you getting help from
someone else who doesn't really know
what your notebook was doing like a
devops engineer or someone like myself a
cyber liability engineer
um in general it's it's pretty tough and
it's kind of a bummer because once you
rewrite your notebook or production you
lose a lot of the nice things you get
with a notebook
um so my goal today is to you know help
you get notebooks to production while
also preserving all the wonderful things
we love about Jupiter notebooks and to
do that
there's this library that I have created
called jupy rest and
um yeah hope is that we know we can use
GPS to take these notebooks to
production and uh you know make writing
web services more fun
so what is jupy rest jupy rest is a
python library that can convert a
Jupiter notebook into essentially a rest
API like a serverless function think of
it like how you deployed uh serverless
functions in AWS Lambda or Azure
functions
um you know you might have like a script
or something like that and then you
deploy it and then it can scale out
scale in this is very much the same
thing except your function is actually a
Jupiter notebook
so
the jupyres library lets you Define
inputs and outputs for each of your
notebooks so that they can be treated
like functions
and just a bit of background
um I created this at Microsoft so it's
been at it's been in production since
about you know 2020 early 2020 and
recently we uh open source on GitHub
under MIT license
which is pretty cool
so let's let's take a look at how we can
do this with a simple example
um
so what how do we turn a notebook into a
function we really we need three things
the first thing is we need an ID ID like
what is this function called it needs to
be there needs to be a name for it
um then there needs to be some uh
parameter schema some kind of input
schema what does this function take in
this take uh taken as inputs and
similarly we need an output schema like
a return value response body all meaning
the same thing but we need to Define
these for our notebook to turn it into a
function
so
let's take a simple notebook here it's
very basic
um it just it's very it's like a hello
world thing
if you're familiar with paper mill you
might see that sell the first cell up
there the parameters tag and no oh
that's like you know that's where we can
inject our parameters but basically what
what that cell means is saying that
these are the parameters for the
notebook and what's in the cell is are
the default parameters so
um in this case The Notebook takes in
one input called name and it's a string
and the default value is world and uh
you know when we call this notebook
we'll we can pass that in as a parameter
and override that
the output you can see there we're
calling a function called save output
from GPRS
um what whatever you pass into this
function is essentially your return
value or response from your notebook
function so when you're running this in
a Jupiter lab it's essentially a no op
but when you actually deploy it to
production it will mean something and
I'll show you that later on but here
we're just we're we're passing in a dict
and you know name is name
so uh the other thing we'll need to do
is to create this Json file and it's
called hello world config.json and I'll
go through each of the sections here
there's three sections
so the first thing is the ID what is
this function called
hello world the second thing is the
input so this is a input schema
definition using Json schema so same
same way you define a Swagger API or
open API definition
here it's yeah it's saying okay it's an
object with a property name and that
name is a string and it's required
similarly the output so this example is
so simple that the output schema is the
same as the input schema but yeah same
deal uh there's uh we use the same like
a swagger like open API like definition
here
and um
if in order to associate one of these
config files with a notebook we have
this naming convention you just make
sure the names are the same so that's
that's really all you need to do to turn
a notebook into a into a function
so
yeah this is how I would look on your
file system
next uh we can download jupy rest and
start up the server so you pip install
and then you run uh that command up
there notice that one of the parameters
is the notebooks directory so GPRS will
take that directory scan it for uh and
look for these notebook functions and
then make those available to you to
execute by a rest API
so let's do that
um if I were to call one of these
functions what I need to do is uh do a
post request like so so this post
request it takes two parameters the
notebook and then parameters The
Notebook
um defined it's like you give the ID of
the notebook function parameters is like
your request body so here we're gaming
name Pi data Seattle and then a notebook
slow world and um you know we did give
an input schema for this so Jupe rest
will validate anything we pass in here
against you know the input schema for
this function ID so if I gave in a list
or some other kind of object then it
would give me a 400 just like any good
rest API would do but this this will
pass that validation
so the response will get you know unlike
um a normal web API notebooks do take
longer I mean they have to like spin up
the Jupiter server and stuff so you what
you'll get is like an execution ID like
a handle that you can go retrieve the
results to up this later
um it's not some you know usually you
don't want to be waiting on this
notebook to finish executing within a
single uh web request but this was a
pretty simple one so it completed pretty
quickly and we get this execution ID and
the status as it's completed
so now how do we get the outputs well
unlike a rest API where you know you get
like a Json output or something we have
a couple different execution artifacts
that we can work with
um and so this is you know how you form
the request to get it you do a get and
then you get the execution ID but you
can have one of these two flags onto it
if you put output equals true then
you'll get whatever thing you saved in
that state output call in that function
so
um you know that would be returned to as
Json the other thing which is you know
very uh just just inherent to notebooks
is that we can actually get the full
notebook itself like as an HTML that you
can view in your browser
so you get one or the other you get the
notebook output or you get the whole
like notebook HTML and you can see all
the intermediate steps if you had tables
charts graphs in there you can all you
can see that as well
so let's start with that because that's
uh uh I guess like more more standard so
this is what that notebook execution
would look like you notice here the
parameters the that I sent in from my
request body have now shown up as a code
cell in the notebook so it overrides
that previous one so now this it becomes
the input to the to the notebook and
then it runs through everything and it
runs I've saved output at the end but
you know really it's like a no-off or it
is you don't really there's nothing like
else there so you get you can kind of
see all the intermediate steps
um if you put output equals true then
you'll see the output which is what we
passed into that save output function
and so now you've basically got this way
of treating a notebook both like a
notebook like you know you could
schedule a notebook to just run and then
you can view what the notebook looks
like but you could also look at the
notebook as something with a clear
well-defined input and output
um so it's sort of like a rest API
um of course you know like I said
notebooks are there are certain cases
where this is not like a good idea if I
was making a web service I need to do
like a million requests per second I
probably wouldn't want to use a notebook
for every one of those things but there
are a lot of cases where a notebook
would be a great place to
um you know flow throughput you know
kind of just
you know use cases that where the
usability just makes a lot more sense
um
so yeah
so just kind of recapping here um before
we get into a little bit more advanced
stuff what have we done we've taken an
existing notebook and then we've turned
it into a rest API with very minimal
changes to the notebook itself
um it was really that same output call
at the very end that was really it and
then the config file which is external
to The Notebook
um so yeah we got the input schema the
output schema we can you know get like a
Json output from The Notebook and um
one of the cool things with this that's
different than a traditional web service
is that
because we can get the full notebook
execution if let's say there is a
problem in the notebook there was a bug
and there was an exception that was
thrown I really don't have to worry
about doing all kinds of like logging or
figuring out where I need to send my
traces it's all in the notebook so I can
just get the notebook execution and I
can see exactly where the failure
happened as if I was running the
notebook on my laptop
so it makes that whole it lets you not
have to figure out that part initially
so you can do you know debugging of your
notebook executions uh really nicely
um just by looking at the notebook uh
with that uhtml flag
so
um and you know we so this was a pretty
popular project in Microsoft we'll use
it for all different types of scenarios
I'll go into you know what some of those
are towards the end but
as people wrote more and more notebooks
we did run into some challenges uh you
know scaling out these types of services
so the big one here is you know let's
say you have like 100 or 200 notebooks
every single one of them is going to
have this config.json file next to it
that defines like what the input and
output is
um what we found is a lot of notebooks
would want to take in the same type of
input but they would do different types
of analysis on it so you want to share
that input schema across many different
notebooks
which like I said if you would it would
if you did it the way I just showed you
would result in a lot of duplicated
schemas which is um not ideal
um
so the question became like how can we
Define a model one one in one place and
then reuse that across
a bunch of different notebooks so that
they can all uh share that so we can
update that once and then our API
contracts will get seamlessly updated as
well
so the example I'm going to be using for
this is like a portfolio analysis let's
say I have a bunch of notebooks that
analyze my stock portfolio they all take
in the same input which is my stock
portfolio but they do various other
things to it so we're going to take that
as an example here and show you how you
can use this sharing models across
notebooks
um so the way I would Define
my model the way that we you know we and
then ended up implementing this in jupy
rest is by uses using plain old python
objects so we have this portfolio class
it's you know it's got a start date and
date and some Holdings and it inherits
from this class called NP schema base
Envy schema base is actually a subclass
of pied Antics based model if you're
familiar with that library but
that's essentially what it is
um so once we've defined our model as a
class like so we need to give it a name
like an alias
um and I'll show you where that comes in
later so for this one we're just
associating the name portfolio to this
class portfolio in this model collection
here
so now that we have this let's try let's
you know use this in our input schemas
um oh actually so this is like an
example of the what the notebook looks
like you can see my parameter cell like
the default parameters is actually just
an instance of this portfolio class so
that's like how you know how it would
look like in The Notebook
um
so this is the config.json for this
notebook
um notice it doesn't have an output
schema that's so both of those are
optional but here we only want to Define
input because that's really only what we
care about
in our input schema we have this ref
here and that's the interesting part so
what this is referring to is the Alias
for a model we defined in Python earlier
so you know that dollar sign rep is just
a standard of construct of Json schema
and we've just defined a different uh
like a custom uh URI scheme here uh and
then jumpyrest will resolve all of these
uh for you when it does the schema
validation
so
um when you send in your request it
would make sure that it has a start date
and end date and the Holdings are look
like what it needs to look like
according to the Titans
so
if I were to call this function
again the client still sends Json so it
just looks like this and you know start
date and date and then my Holdings and
then like the weights of like what
percentage of my portfolio is this stock
and um
yeah when I execute this notebook the
executed notebook will look like this
this is just the parameter cells so you
notice the top are the default
parameters
the bottom are actually the injected
parameters so what jupiterus did is when
the client sent the post request it saw
the payload and it said oh you know this
actually needs to be an instance of the
portfolio class
so we it wrote this python code and
inserted it into the notebook so there's
no
um you don't have to worry about any
Json serialization deserialization
nothing like that your notebook can use
these plain old python objects and you
know if you use if you can if you use
that NB schema reference in your Json
schema uh jupis will generate the code
for you and put it right into your
notebook so you can start using your
notebook with python objects you don't
have to really care that it's in Json or
anything like that that all happens
under the hood so you can even see the
date time like the date objects have
been converted into date Optics they
were actually strings here but because
we defined it as a date the start date
and date as date objects in our
portfolio class those got transparently
converted
into the appropriate object so you you
don't even have to parse that which is
really cool
so
um yeah
so what do we have here we basically now
can describe a whole API using just
python objects we can describe we can
get to use all the wonderful things we
get with python classes like inheritance
class methods instance methods
um you know pedantic itself lets you run
like custom validations for every single
property of your class so you get you
get all of that too so it's really uh
focused on the code first approach here
we're not trying to make you write a
whole bunch of config you know
um ideally your you have those
config.json files should be pretty small
once they get pretty big you're like
okay maybe I'll just put this as a
python class in my code and then refer
to it using that ref
um and that also helps because now your
notebook code can just work with python
objects it doesn't even need to know
that it's a rest API
um there are a lot of like different
solutions to this that would have you
like rewrite the beginning and the end
of your notebook but we really wouldn't
want to do that we wanted like someone
who just wrote a notebook look just with
pure python can take it almost as is and
turn it into a rest API so
um this uh this was a pretty uh once we
rolled this out within the company this
is also a very popular feature
um that made it writing and Publishing
notebooks a lot easier and also managing
them at scale
so
within Microsoft so this was uh so the
initial intent or like the problem that
I had sought to solve with this was
um centered around cyber liability
engineering with run books if anyone's
been on like an on-call rotation before
you might be familiar with those they're
just essentially some document that you
know when you get an incident some issue
happened you will look for a particular
document that tells you step by step
what to do to handle that like incident
response
um so a lot of these documents were
written as like markdown some of the
might have been Jupiter notebooks but
they're all manually
um you know consumed or like the
notebooks are mainly run on the laptop
so what we use with jupy rest is we
could take these notebooks and deploy
them as a service so that when an
incident comes in we can say we can link
up like a web hook so that everything
incidents created it can run one or more
of these notebook runbooks
and to basically do the whole analysis
of whatever the issue is the output of
the notebook would be a very concise set
of steps for that on-call engineer like
what they need to do to fix the problem
and if they ever needed to say like well
how did we get to this conclusion that
we need to go set this configuration on
this VM or something like that the
notebook itself would have all that
analysis because now you can do the view
HTML and see the full log of like what
did it look at what to investigate what
things did it rule out and so you could
like really like cram it with all kinds
of Like You Know Rich artifacts in there
because that's what Jupiter notebooks
are great at
um no need to like look at blocks or
anything like that
um
and another thing this really helped
with was let's say an incident happens a
week later you have like a post incident
review if you want to look at like a do
a postmortem having these notebook
executions was really helpful because it
basically stored all of the analysis in
these notebook forms for us so that
later on we can go pull them out and say
like oh why did we do this why did we do
that the notebook has everything so no
need for someone to go manually write
these summaries we could literally just
attach these notebooks to a postmortem
and present them right after the fact so
it just sped up the whole process
um
and because notebooks are super flexible
obviously running them as a service is
cool but you can also run them on your
laptop and so whenever there's like a
new issue someone can pull up a notebook
quickly write something you know fix the
problem that they're trying to fix and
then deploy it like the next day into
our service so that the next time the
incident comes we'll pick it up and
automate it like that
so that's
that's like the use case that you know
GPS was built for initially but there
are a lot of other like data science uh
jobs and you know data analysis jobs
that people started using this for
um
because of course Jupiter has a great
tooling for that as well so
um it's it's pretty so that's why we
decided to open source the
infrastructure you know um because it
was very generic and we thought it might
be useful for other people to use but
this is essentially where we started
from um sort of like the devops uh
perspective
so when we deploy this internally of
course you can run this locally and do
all your testing locally but
within uh Azure we basically built this
as an extension to Azure functions so
Azure functions you know it was a that
was nice because we didn't really want
to build a yet another serverless
platform we just build on top of one
that's already there the other Advantage
is that Azure functions the whole
runtime is open source too and it can
let you deploy on-prem or in kubernetes
it has all of those options uh available
so it gave us more flexibility through
there so yet another reason for US Open
sources as well
and like I said we did have people use
this for more like data sciency and like
running like ml models so in order to
support those use cases we did allow for
a different notebook execution backends
so the ones we have are like Azure
synapse and then you know Azure
databricks
um
but you know there could be more like I
don't I don't know about the apis about
the collab but like that could be
another one
um where you can run these notebooks and
that's a cool thing with notebooks is
that it once you get all your code into
a notebook there's many different places
you can ship it to go get it run and so
uh another reason why it's it's such a
great place to write these kind of web
services
um that you don't really need like super
high throughput but you do want like
that visibility and flexibility
um
yeah so
this is a little bit about me if you
want to find me on GitHub and then
that's the link to the uh the GitHub
repo it is we're still like it is my job
to slowly open source portions of this
as like developments happening actively
internally so it's definitely not like
GA or preview yet but it is being
actively developed there's like a team
of like 10 people at Microsoft now that
are working on this so it's just my job
to make sure all their work gets seen by
the public uh so yeah if you're curious
about this you know find me after the
talk I'd love to chat about this but
that's um that's all I have for you
today and uh yeah thanks for call coming
to my talk
any questions from the audience I've got
a mic and I'll bring it to you
thanks I love to talk um I was just
wondering if there was anything like
high level for next steps like you say
there's people working on it like what
are some of the things you're working on
um so
next steps like from for the open source
part like if there's a lot of next steps
that you know are just like bringing
like the infrastructure that we have
internally and making that open source
um I think like apart from that it would
probably be I mean one thing is like the
ability to run one notebook from another
or do like almost like airflow but like
be able to like call airflow within a
notebook and then have like a scheduler
that does that because that's that's
been like a a ask
um within the company
um because if you have a bunch of little
notebooks that do small useful things
but then you want to kind of run them
all in one dag it we didn't really have
a solution for that but I would say that
would be one and also supporting like
other languages other kernels
um so people can write in some other
languages other than Python and get the
benefits of this
other than python I don't understand
there are yeah
[Music]
Python's the easiest though by far
I've set a question about like the
deployment of the notebooks themselves
like it seemed very simple if you have
the notebook and the config file
together on your laptop how that would
work but if somebody like if our
incident response team is like offshore
and what kind of deployment
requirements are they going to have like
if that Jupiter notebook is sitting on
my laptop I assume they can't access it
or is it like
something about the API
ID that you're putting in that allows
them to access something that's scored
locally on my laptop I just wasn't sure
exactly how that worked yeah yeah so
um no one can run a notebook that's on
your laptop so that's that's definitely
not a thing
um but if you would deploy this how you
would deploy any other like web service
so it would be you would check it into
some Source control like git and then do
a code review and then once it's good
you merge it into the main branch and
then you know deploy it to in in our
case would be deployed as like an Azure
function so we have like a you know like
a temp like a pipeline like deployment
Pipeline and we just piggyback on the
Azure functions deployment model so
um that so we just follow followed that
but yeah there's definitely every
notebook is like code and so if it's on
your laptop it's great and that's only
for you but if we want to make it
available for everyone it does have to
go through like a code review process
and then a deployment and all that
first thank you for sharing this I think
you probably want to ask everybody to go
give you a start and GitHub for your
project as well it's more uh you know
awareness second have you thought about
anything of you know it's past question
uh you know creating an easy button to
say hey I want to publish this notebook
as an Azure function
uh yeah so that's that's part of the
things part of the things I need to like
open source we do have like a like a
Marketplace app where like you can't
like a button on GitHub to deploy it
it's just um I gotta get rid of all the
internal configs and and but yeah that's
certainly possible to uh deploy to have
like something like easy to deploy like
that
everyone
no thank you very much
[Applause]